un véritable coup de coeur sans mauvais
jeu de mots c'est ainsi qu'aider le lien
entre francine leca la fondatrice de
mécénat chirurgie cardiaque et le maire
de villepreux jean baptiste à monique
francine leca c'est un personnage
professeur de médecine elle fut la
première femme chirurgien cardiaque en
france et elle a fondé en 1996
l'association mécénat chirurgie
cardiaque
cette association permet à des enfants
atteints de malformations cardiaques
mais qui ne peuvent pas être opéré dans
leur pays d'origine d'être prises en
charge en france dont des centres de
chirurgie cardiaque pédiatrique et
d'être ainsi sauvé comme l'expliquent
francine leca ils étaient partis
souffreteux bleus fatigué et rentre en
pleine forme en ayant grossi d' quelques
kilos et c'est toujours la grande fierté
des familles d'accueil quand on les
revoit après l'opération ils nous disent
tout de suite et l'après 3 kg le ca c et
c'est vrai parce que je dis toujours
quand on mange bien et qu'on dort bien
c'est qu'on va bien mais pour s'occuper
de ses enfants les loger les nourrir il
faut bien entendu des familles d'accueil
bien sûr et ça c'est un appel pressant
et intense que je fais à toutes les
familles qui voudront pendant un mois et
demi environ de moyenne accueillir un
petit enfant
lui est de contribuer fortement à lui
redonner la santé à faire d'un petit
enfant souffreteux est malade un enfants
plein de vie c'est pour les familles une
lourde charge il faut le reconnaître
mais un bonheur toujours magnifique il
faut aussi de l'argent environ 12000
euros par enfant d'où l'opération une
histoire de coeur menée par jean
baptiste à monique lemaire de villepreux
et son collègue de port marly cédric pin
bas marine les deux villes vont s'allier
pour sauver deux enfants une soirée de
gala un concert sont d'ores et déjà
prévues mais plus encore les deux maires
vont mouiller le maillot et pas qu'un
peu ils vont en effet participer au
marathon des sables une centaine de
kilomètres de course à pied par jour
comme l'expliquent jean baptiste à
monique on partira le soir même du
concert d'ailleurs au domaine de
grand'maisons partira le 25 septembre
pour revenir le 2 octobre ces quatre
jours de course
en autosuffisance alimentaire c'est à
dire qu'on part avec notre pacte h
pendant les quatre jours on a que l'eau
qui nous est ravitaillé et après à nous
de cheminée à nous de dormir et de
planter nos tentes le soir et puis à
supporter la chaleur supporter ce
supporter mutuellement si on a
l'habitude on y arrivera et puis oui
aller mouiller le maillot parce que
l'idée c'est de remarquer tout le monde
c'est de fédérer tout le monde autour de
ce projet là mais il faut qu'on puisse
montrer l'exemple il va nous falloir un
peu d'entraînement va falloir qu'on
dégage un peu de temps dans nos agendas
assez chargé de mer pour nous entraîner
parce que comme le disait cédric tout à
l'heure l'abandon n'est pas une option
une opération dont tv 78 partenaires
nous suivre 11 évidemment de près la
course de ces deux mères qui s'engage
pour que des bouts de chou condamnés
puissent mener la vie normale d'un
enfant quoi de plus beau